[Musique]
il y aurait moyen que dit et moi on
vienne à tafer de décembre a tapé
chaudes thé pas invité basta vont être
invités pour pécho vous passez nasa
coule plus que moi et mes potes on est
un peu galère je voudrais savoir si tu
serais partante pour m'apprendre un mois
et quelques potes comme monde du show
des miss weight inquiète on est sauvés
min ça sera 10 euros la leçon et par
personne
vous allez me dire chacun vous tout ce
que vous avez d'original ans ferme
honneur voilà je suis chef de tout si je
suis comment tu me lis les en fait on me
démarquer j'ai mon amour de la danse ça
va être compliqué là ils partent de
super interroge la première chose que
brahim fc votre gueule c'est comme pour
les apparts elle met trois secondes
avoue choisir comment attirer
l'attention des meufs avec le regard tu
côtoies y échappe était trop belle on
voit que toi même quand t'es pas là bah
voila j'ai trouvé que l'on se démarquer
vous allez me rendre à deux balles
l'amour c'est une dit en plus finement
ce que si l'amour pour vous c'est la
merde rebondir ce que ça vaut le coup
évidemment
et fais moi confiance un tout petit peu
plus que je vous le meilleur pour toi
nous on les voit encore comme des petits
bd mais ils ont grandi mais j'ai pas
envie de valider une relation amoureuse
dite sérieuse à 15 ans l'amour c'est
être avec toi pour faire tout et c'est
aussi les deux sens fort
et pensez twittant
et vous enseigne comme empêchant que ça
et aller voir une fille de joie
non mr touche pas la gueule